Please put your hands
together for Daniel Dennett
can, can I ask how slice to
be put up a, I'm not an actor.
I'm a professor. I liked it. I
liked to see the students' eyes.
I like to see the audience reactions.
I feel very uncomfortable
if I can't do that. Okay.
So my new book is called from
bacteria to Bach and back. And
let's see, oh yeah, turn
it on. All his helps.
That's a bacterium and that's buck.
And I'm going to say a
little bit about them,
but mainly today I'm going to talk about
back cause that's what you folks come
in. Yes, Google actually is uh,
not just mentioned in the book but uh,
discussed a little bit in the last
chapter. So we'll get to that.
But first I have to give a sort of
swift review of how I got there.
So here's the great tree of life.
This is my favorite diagram.
I just realized there's all these screens.
I can't use my, my laser pointer.
So I have to use the, um,
cursor here. Aha. Here we are. So if you,
this is the present out here at the
outer edge and this is the origin of life
here.
So time goes this way.
Everything that's alive
on the planet today,
there's somewhere out there on that
fringe and you can see how it started with
the archaea and the bacteria.
And then you had this amazing event.
This was the, you carry Arctic
Revolution, the endosymbiosis,
the creative that you carry.
Odic sell
the first great technology transfer
to independent simple cells,
bumped into each other and
instead of one eating the other,
they joined forces and
it just happened to work.
And thus was the eukaryotic cell born
and everything that's alive that's big
enough to see with the naked eye is a,
you carry out where are you carry outs.
So were pine trees and whales
and birds and everything else.
Everything else except for
bacteria and some other protests.
So this huge colorful fan out all the
sequel to chance event that happened,
uh,
several billion years ago.
And then here is another familiar feature.
You may have heard of the
Cambrian explosion over a
relatively short period of
time,
a few million years,
relatively short by evolutionary biology,
biology standards.
You had a tremendous creative
burst of new designs,
novelty, and of course along with the
creativity when a lot of destruction,
mass extinctions along with the,
it wasn't a tremendous arms race.
I'll have more to say about that later.
And so then over way over here somewhere
we have the mammals and let's just a
look a little bit larger at the mammals
and let's look at even a little bit
larger.
And if we look,
see that little y there right there,
that's about 6 million years each leg.
So that could be the chimps and Bonobos
on one leg, enough on the other.
That's how recent hominids are us
and and modern homosapiens of course,
it's much more recent still.
So there we are,
just that just a tiny little
twig on the tree of life.
So there's the tree of life.
And I like that particular diagram because
it helps us to visualize the history
of life on the planet as a history of
r and d of a research and development.
Um,
it's a design process that exploits
information in the environment to create,
maintain,
and improve the design of things.
I do not shrink from talking
about design by evolution.
I think it's a mistake of evolutionary
biologist say we're not going to talk
about design because that gives aid and
comfort to the ID intelligent design
crowd. No, the, the,
the brilliant designs of evolution,
if that isn't designed nothing is because
it outstrips human design often by,
by many degrees. Uh, let's agree.
It's designed without an intelligent
designer. That's Darwin's idea.
I have more to say about that. Well, R
and d takes time and energy as you know.
And there were two main varieties.
There's evolution by natural selection
and then there's human intelligent
design, low lower case. I lower case d.
Ours are intelligence designers.
The rum is full of them.
You were intelligent designers
and you're not alone.
And there had been intelligent
designers for quite a while,
but not for millions of views there.
I've only been intelligent designers
for a hundred thousand years,
which is just barely visible
on the map of the tree of life.
We're a very,
very,
very recent development and if we read
back features of our own intelligent
design into nature at our peril,
there are very important lessons to learn
about that effort to reverse engineer
nature. And I, I indulge
in it throughout the book,
but there are things you have to be
careful about because the process is
different. Fundamental ways.
Evolution of course is purposeless.
Foresight lists extremely costly,
trillions and trillions and quadrillions
of poor organisms die childless.
Okay.
Oh, 99% of everything that's
ever lived, died, childless,
an awful lot of waste.
And of course it's slow.
It takes billions of years.
Contrast that with intelligent design,
which is purposeful goal directed.
It's somewhat four sided.
Why does foresighted is it often thinks
it is and of course it's governed by
cost considerations as you all know.
Well,
okay.
And it's usually relatively fast.
Even though,
as you also know,
particularly in the world of software,
projects always take
longer than you expect,
even when you expect them to
take longer than you expect.
So evolution may be slow and costly,
but it is brilliant.
Uh,
the late great Sir Francis
Crick once made a joke about it,
a teasing in a way his colleague Leslie
or goal by calling it [inaudible] second
rule evolution. That's
clever. And you are,
and what he meant is not he,
nobody on earth would ever be less
likely to be a supporter of ID,
intelligent design. Then Francis
Crick, that was not his point.
His point is that the process of
natural selection though mindless,
purposeless without imagination.
Nevertheless,
it produces designs that are more cunning,
more devious,
and more efficient than most
human beings can imagine.
That's what he meant.
So intelligent design now exists,
as I say,
the room is this where
we are sitting in a,
in a veritable castle
of intelligent design
and it's becoming ever more intelligent.
And a lot of you can take
some credit for that too.
And this has some surprising implications.
Okay.
Here's an interesting comparison.
Yeah.
On the left,
you see an Australian termite
castle on the right you see Goudis,
famous Barcelona church Sagrada Familia.
They're remarkably similar in overall
shape and structure and material.
And even the interior design.
There are many features and com it
says sort of breathtakingly interesting
comparison.
So the end product is dry.
They're strikingly similar.
But the processes by which these products
have been made are hugely different.
These are my exemplars of a point.
I want a contrast.
I want to stress the termite
castle is made by termites,
millions of them.
And in a word they're clueless.
They don't know what they're doing,
they don't know why they're doing it.
There's no boss termites, there's no
architect, termites, there's no, uh,
subcontractors and contractors.
They all just doing their
little local mindless jobs.
And amazingly the termite castle with
many outstanding design features like air
conditioning, uh, emerges from,
they're very competent but
clueless behavior Goudy.
On the other hand,
it was just perfect for my purposes
cause he's the archetypal charismatic,
mad genius Eero,
the top down king of design who had
blueprints and manifestos and proof of
concept and and it was all planned
out in advance and he lord it over his
assistance who Lord it over
their assistance, who lorded
over their assistance,
who lorded it over the brick layers
and stone cutters and others who built.
So we have Goudy as an exemplar of
cop down design and the termites as an
exemplar of bottom up design.
I think that's pretty clear.
Now here's a puzzle.
We have bottom up design
and we have top down design.
I'm just giving you some examples.
Now a termite colony might be as many
as say 70 million clueless termites,
a brain latest count,
86 billion,
even more clueless neurons.
Your brain is much more like a termite
colony. The new might like to think
there's no boss, there's no boss
Neuron, there's no head architect,
there's no lieutenants
and captains and generals.
Just 86 billion,
a little mindless neurons and doing their
thing and having even less knowhow and
versatility in many ways.
Then then the termites.
Okay,
so now here's the question.
How do you get a gouty type mind
out of a termite colony? Brands?
I think it's obvious to
everybody that a termite colony,
wonderful though they are.
They're never going to write any poems.
They're not going to have
a new form of government.
They're not going to build ships.
They're not going to do any of a
kazillion things that we've done,
and yet the whole column me,
how's it structure,
which is not all that different
from the structure of our brains.
The neurons are semi autonomous,
quite independent.
They live their own little lives and they
grow up around in their local spaces,
not unlike termites. So there's
the puzzle. Now, what's the answer?
Well,
the short answer,
which is nicely been put by a former
student of mine, bulldog album,
you can't do much carpentry with your
bare hands and you can't do much thinking
with your bare brain.
You're bear brand is like a termite
colony. It can't too much thinking.
It's very competent at some things,
but it can't do much thinking and it
can't because it doesn't have the thinking
tools.
A termite colony is a bear brain.
Intelligent designers have well equipped
brains equipped with thinking tools.
Where did they get their tools?
Well,
the wrong answer,
this from Freeman Dyson technology is
a gift of God after the gift of life.
It is perhaps the greatest of God's gifts.
Who is the mother of civilizations
of Arts and sciences?
The Freeman is a sweet man.
The passengers I'm quoting,
the first sentence is false and the
rest of that, I think that's true.
So we have to replace that first
sentence with something more plausible,
something more naturalistic.
So if that's the wrong answer,
here's the long answer.
Cultural Evolution,
cultural evolution,
the process of natural
selection of cultural items,
design thinking tools that imposing
novel structures on our brains.
What happened over not billions of years,
but only over thousands of years.
It was cultural evolution is very fast,
is that virtual machines we're evolved
that could travel and spread and be
installed on different brains giving
those brands powers they otherwise didn't
have.
Or as I like to put it,
there are apps that we
download into our neck tops
and I mean that almost literally
our basic mammalian brains
or like a computer without
even an operating system
or with only a rudimentary
operating system.
And then we pile in the apps
and many apps depending on other apps,
which depending on other apps,
and in the end you have a multi competent
entity that can do things that
the bear brain can't do by itself.
Okay.
And that's the power,
the source of our power and versatility.
Well that's the long answer,
but very shortly put,
I want to know spell it out in a little
more detail because I want to highlight
a few of the important
features of this idea,
which many people find
shocking and repugnant.
And I want to acknowledge that and
expose it so we can move on from that.
So we have to go back to my favorite
passage from a critic of Darwin's who
talked about Darwin.
Strange inversion of reasoning.
I read this over the years.
Many times.
I still love to read it because it
expresses the outrage so perfectly.
And I'm going to attempt to do it in a
sort of Oxbridge accent accent because
the author who was originally a anonymous,
uh, in the book in which he said
this, he's listed, uh, in the,
uh, on the title page is simply a
graduate of Cambridge University.
So here is what you've said in the theory
with which we'd have to do absolute
ignorance,
AI
absolute ignorance is the art Visser
so that we may not see it as the
fundamental principle of the whole system,
that in order to make a
perfect and beautiful machine,
it is not requisite to know how
to make it. The caps are in,
the original
proposition will be filed on Koval
examination to express and condensed form,
you know,
central poor port of the theory and to
express in a few words all Mr Darwin's
meaning who by a strange inversion of
reasoning seems like absolute ignorance,
fully qualified to take the place of
absolute wisdom in all the two points of
creatives skill.
Exactly.
He's nailed it.
That's what Darwin did.
And it was a strange
inversion of reasoning.
Why do we send our children to university?
So did they get the wisdom so that they
can then do achievements of creative
skill? Here's Darwin saying it's
the other way around. Now we can,
we can get brilliant design
out of absolute ignorance.
Well,
the idea was appealing to many people,
but it really needed
another great Brit too.
Oh, show in detail how this might work.
And that's my second hero, Alan Turing.
And here's Turing strange and version
of reasoning. First of all, remember,
here's Darwin's strange version in
order to make it perfect and beautiful
machine that's not requisite
for know how to make it.
Here's touring's in order to be a
perfect and beautiful computing machine,
it is not requisite to
know what arithmetic is.
What Turing had figured out was
that the computers of his day,
who were people,
many of them wearing dresses,
women who would read
mathematics in university,
that their jobs could be replaced by a
machine from which all the comprehension
we're sort of laundered out.
And that was the dawn of the computer age.
So Darwin and touring together
have a common theme, which, uh,
is expressed in my, I suppose this
is my bumper sticker. Now these days,
competence without comprehension,
competence without comprehension.
The upshot of this is very
alarming to many people.
That means that mind consciousness,
understanding, intentionality,
it's the effects,
not the cause.
The traditional view with God,
the intelligent designer providing all
the meaning and purpose and it sort of
trickling down to the creations.
Throw that away.
It's not a mind first universe.
It's a matter first universe.
Mine is a very recent
development on this planet.
Termites are not intelligent designers.
Beavers are not very
intelligent designers.
We are the first intelligent
designers and the tree of life.
And we come along very recently,
but what a difference we've made.
I want to talk about the
McCready explosion. I mentioned
the Cambrian explosion.
I want to talk about an even
more dramatic explosion,
which I call the McCreaty explosion.
Paul MacCready,
how many of you know who he is?
He's a late great green engineer.
The gossamer Albatross,
the pedal power of the human powered plane
that flew across the English Channel.
That's one of Paul is brilliant creations,
uh,
of a real visionary man,
a wonderful stuff.
And he wrote a paper not so many years
ago where he calculated that 10,000 years
ago,
a twinkling in evolutionary time,
the human population plus their livestock.
This is as agriculture was just
getting going 10,000 years ago.
If you took the human population at the
time plus all their livestock and pets,
it was probably in the order of a 10th
of a percent by weight of the terrestrial
vertebrate biomass of the animals.
We're leaving out all the insects in
the worms and the fish in the sea,
terrestrial vertebrate biomass a
fraction of 1% 10,000 years ago.
The percent today is rather hire.
Would anybody hazard a guess?
95% no, that's low. It's 98.
Yeah,
we have in golf the planet,
most of that is cattle.
But this is
probably the biggest,
fastest
biological change on the planet ever.
And this happened in 10,000 years.
And genes don't explain it.
Technology explains it.
And Technology is not
transmitted through the genes
did, it was in fact the result of
another great technology transfer.
I already described the eukaryotic
revolution where to to produce cells to
prokaryotic cells,
each with a billion year lineage of r
and d to give them the talents that they
had joined forces.
And suddenly you had this multitalented
new things that you carry odic cell
that was a fee can happy
event if ever there was one.
The next one
is the invasion of human brains
by symbiotic thinking tools means
a term of course is from
Richard Dawkins the selfish,
I don't know if you've read the
selfish gene, how have you haven't,
we'll put it on your list.
It is.
It is one of the great science
books of the 20th century.
And uh,
uh,
it is often denigrated and dissed
by people who's scared of it.
It is still to this day was published
in [inaudible] 76 probably the single
best,
clearest and most exciting a survey of
what we know about evolution but it's
been written.
And in that book,
the selfish gene,
he also wrote about a new kind of
replicator, which you call it a meme,
a selfish meme,
which are like jeans are like viruses,
they are cultural
replicators and like viruses.
A virus travels like it doesn't carry
its own replication machinery with it.
It has to invade a cell and commandeer
the copy machine in that cell to make
copies of it rather than the, the, the uh,
DNA that the cell was supposed to copy.
And he suggested that culture was
composed of entities that were similarly
capable of provoking their own
replication by invading brains
we don't inherit means via our genes.
We learn them from our parents,
from our peers, from our friends,
from television.
We are constantly bombarded with ideas.
Some of them stick, some of them
go in one ear out. The other,
the ones that stick take up residence in
our brain and then they have to compete
for life support with all the others
that are trying to get in there.
And every time you think it,
you make an offspring.
Every time you say a word, you make
another copy. Every time you think a word,
you make another copy
and words of the best examples of mutes.
I'll get to that.
I'm getting a little bit of edit myself.
The main point though for our purposes
here is that we don't have to design them
ourselves.
We are the beneficiaries of thousands
of years of cultural evolution.
We don't,
we don't have to design alphabetizing
lists are long division or,
or,
uh,
plain geometry or calculus or,
uh, how to write music or the, uh, uh,
well tempered scale or a
perspective or I could go on forever.
Of course,
these are all highly
developed ways of doing things
that
or not instincts,
instincts are ways of doing things
that are passed through the germline,
through the,
through the DNA.
Memes are just like instincts,
their ways of doing things,
but they're not passed through
the germline. They are,
they are picked up perceptually,
uh,
socially.
Many in most cases,
we don't have to design them ourselves.
In fact, nobody has to design them.
Okay.
So the McCready explosion isn't an
explosive amplification of competence,
which eventually it started off being
competence without comprehension.
I think it's very important to
realize that our early ancestors,
the first at the first hominids infected
with memes were still pretty clueless.
They didn't know what they were doing.
They didn't think of it as cultural.
They didn't think of it as anything.
They just had all these new
habits that were infectious,
that got them doing things
that they hadn't done before.
And it turned out that these built
and built and built and built,
and pretty soon they had language and
then they had epic poetry and then they
had, uh, architecture and boat
building off to the races.
We go
and be evolved into
competence with comprehension.
So finally we get to
comprehension the dark.
So it's the Darwinian strange
inversion reinvented. We get a move,
a trend away from bottom up competence
without comprehension to the evolution of
a different kind of
designing,
which is competence with comprehension.
To understand this, we have to
understand free floating rationales.
Trees do things.
I know some people don't like that term.
I'm sort of sorry I coined it when I did,
but it's sticking and,
and I can't go back and change it now
and in a way it's sort of evocative
because what I mean by a free
floating rationale is a reason,
a real objective reason why
something is the way it is.
That was never anybody's reason until
some clever person analyze the thing and
figure it out retrospectively
what it was good for trees to do,
things for reasons that
trees don't know them,
that they aren't reasons that
the trees have and consider,
but they do lots of things for
reasons fun. G Do things for reason.
Bacteria do things for reasons.
The biotic world is saturated with
reasons from the molecular scale on it.
There are reasons why the parts inside
the bacterium have the shapes they do and
have the powers they do and
fit together the way they do.
And we can reverse engineer these.
Don't think that those reasons were the
reasons represented in the head of any
intelligent designer ever.
They just were uncovered and
exploited by natural selection.
And now we clever reasoners that we
are can sometimes go back and reverse
engineer them and uncover the reasons
that then become represented for the very
first time. When we write
about it, talk about it,
argue about whether this is the
reason for that is a reason,
something is the way it is. And we
do things for a reason. We shiver,
we vomit, we blink and we don't
have to know why we do it,
but there are reasons and
there are good reasons.
And then there's the things that we do
where we choose and decide and we act for
reasons.
Sometimes we do that without even
appreciating that we're doing that
retrospectively, we may figure out,
oh, it was a good reason for that.
And of course sometimes we
confabulating sometimes on purpose.
How many of you have ever
made a move in a chess game,
which only later you realized
it was a brilliant move.
And did you admit it?
I,
there was a very good reason for them.
I didn't think about it at the time,
but it slowly dawned on me
that phenomenon I am arguing is much,
much more frequent than we
think because we tend to uh,
advertise all of our successes
with retrospective accounts
of the reasoning that
led up to them.
And it may be in some sense be accurate.
We're actually reverse
engineering how we got there.
But that doesn't mean we
thought of it at the time.
It doesn't mean we had the reasons in
mind cause you don't need a mind to act
for reasons.
That's one of the lessons.
So the problem that culture
solves is it is the question,
how do you get a buck tight mine
out of a termite colony brain?
How do we get intelligent design with
representation of reasons out of 86
billion mindless neurons?
Yeah.
And that was the second great
endosymbiotic revolution,
Huh?
We are apes with infected brains.
Our brains have been colonized by
all of these viral like things.
A virus has an alive,
but it evolves.
Some people think viruses are alive.
You can argue about that,
but viroids at least.
All right, what are they?
A virus is a string of nuclear
cas who'd with attitude.
It just happens to have a shape that
gives it the competence to provoke its own
replication. Uh, under many circumstances.
Meme similarly are things made
out of information with attitude.
They provoke their own replication
and they don't have to understand this.
This is just the secret of their success.
We're now ready to look
at cultural evolution and,
uh, nobody in this room I think will be
intimidated by such a simple diagram,
but I find that for many audiences
have to sort of lead them through this.
This is one of Peter Godfrey
Smith's Darwinian spaces. Uh, uh,
we can't easily imagine four
dimensions or more. So w we,
well if we want to imagine
changes in evolution,
not only in things evolving but in
the very process of evolution itself,
we can take various features
of the evolutionary phenomena
and map them on three
dimensions in a, in a three
space and then put things on the,
on the,
on the Cuban various places.
So in this case we're going to
put a down at zero zero zero.
We're going to put very
Darwinian evolution.
That is to say this is um,
uh,
no competent, no comprehension
at all. Mindless trial and error,
a random search, uh, bottom up.
So if you like it sort of
Termite Castle type R and d.
Okay. Up in the upper right hand
corner, your far right hand corner.
I put intelligent design,
which is high and comprehension involves
top down methods and involve directed
search,
purposefully directed search.
So now the question is how do we get
from the lower left hand corner to the
upper right hand corner in
a hundred thousand years?
And what I want to argue is that evolution
itself evolved as cultural evolution
got under way the products of cultural
evolution change the very terms of of
selection so that the process of evolution
was sped up and sped up and made more
efficient.
The searches became less
blind and trial and error.
The organization of the
searches became more top down,
who comprehension level gradually goes
up and we ended up not at the pinnacle
but close to it.
Okay.
I put Picasso,
I put the termite castle down in the
lower left and I'm putting Picasso up in
the upper right hand corner.
Not because he was the most
intelligent designer ever
will because he said he was.
He once said,
[inaudible] the truth,
I don't search,
I find
I just get it without any
grubby trial and error.
No way ratios,
no false starts.
I just leap with my God like genius to
the Mount Everest peak in the fitness
landscape and Bingo,
I created another masterpiece.
Well,
[inaudible] partial truth.
My answer is married,
not true.
It's an ideal of creative intelligence
that even Picasso could not meet.
And in fact, if you look at his work, you
see that he made, sometimes it doesn't,
sometimes even hundreds of variations
on a drawing or a painting. Uh, uh,
before he stopped working on that,
his part of his genius layer and the
fact that unlike a lot of other artists,
he signed those and sold them.
Imagine if you could
do that with software.
Okay.
So I'm going to replace
Picasso with Barak,
who really is an exemplary in was
an exemplary intelligent designer.
Deep comprehension of what he was doing.
It was highly constrained
trial and error methods.
He was a very fast composer,
cantata a week for years.
Amazing.
And it was constrained by knowledge,
by comprehension, by foresight.
He really knew what he was doing
and he had purpose and foresight.
He was magnificently
equipped with thinking tools.
He couldn't have existed before the,
the system for writing music out
and instruments like the Oregon.
And in fact,
he wasn't just an organist.
He was more famous in his day as
an organist and as a composer.
He was in Oregon repair man.
He understood Oregon's from
an engineering perspective.
So he really does make an
exemplary intelligent designer.
He had music theory,
he had the history of music,
vast knowledge, this, these
are the thinking tools he used.
Now we're ready to look at a comparison.
Okay,
I thank Matt Ridley for this slide.
Wonderful writer about evolution.
On the left you see an
national and hand axe.
They were made by our ancestors for
about a million years without any change.
It's one of the strangest artifacts ever.
A million years without any change
on the right you'd see a mouse,
nobody invented the Ashmolean hand axe.
Douglas Engelbart invented the mouse.
The was invented
when back in the 70s maybe
late sixties so almost extinct.
It may soon be extinct.
That's the difference in speed of cultural
evolution measured on the big scale
of the tree of life.
So here's our diagram again.
First thing I want to acknowledge us
that we're not the only species that has
some cultural evolution.
Chimpanzees have a several traditions of,
of not cracking and have a termite
fishing or aunt fishing that are passed on
non genetically. And there's
different traditions in different,
in different troops. And that's where
it stops. It never goes cumulative.
It never goes recursive had never piles up
there.
They're not a one trick pony,
but there are about a three trick pony.
But now I want to talk about our cultural
evolution and all the things that are
made of information. These are some of
the most important things in our lives.
You are very familiar.
You are living in this world
of things made of information.
They have to have a physical embodiment.
This is dualism.
But what matters
in every case,
there's something that you can send from
a to B in a bit string if you want to.
You can't send a bowl of soup
that way.
So now let's look at the key
elements of cultural influence, uh,
cultural evolution in our species.
And I think words are the key elements.
And I want to suggest that the first
words that existed were what we might call
sin anthropic words.
Now ascending,
sending thropic species is a
species which is not domesticated,
but has evolved by natural selection
to thrive and human company.
Mice, rats, squirrels,
barn swallows,
bedbugs,
cockroaches, and many, many more.
Those are sending thropic species.
The first words were like that.
Nobody owned them. Nobody.
People didn't even hardly notice
that they were using them. They use,
we're just habits that they developed.
I go into this from a lot
more detail in the book.
Next we get domesticated words and as
Darwin tells us that the key feature of
domestication is you
control the reproduction of
yeah, animal. So
do you have a vocabulary? Those are
your words. You have your vocabulary,
50 60 70 80,000 words,
and if you ever catch yourself about to
say one word and then replacing it with
another word, reframing what
you say before you blurt it out.
Most are domesticated words.
You're controlling their replication,
not perfectly,
but you're playing a strong role
in which words get replicated when,
and a lot of this is beneath notice,
but nevertheless,
this leads to differential replication.
And the words are not all was wonderful.
I like to tell my students that there are,
um,
it's quite possible for there to be a,
a word or an expression
which is of no utility,
whatever,
but which catches on and which has
because it has its own fitness.
It doesn't have to boost your fitness.
It just has to be able to survive.
And one day a student said,
uh, can you give me an example?
I said, well, it's like if you are,
I'm like talking about some subject like,
and uh,
like it occurs to you that like maybe
there would be a word in the sentence that
like he didn't have to use all.
And he said,
I get the point.
I want an example.
It's very important that memes
can evolve without human notice.
Even though they involve the
utilization of human perception,
the pronunciation of a trim
or the meaning of a term,
who gradually shift over your lifetime
or over a couple of generations or over a
few years. And suddenly
you may notice, oh my gosh,
this used to mean something else.
Now it means something different.
Happens all the time.
That's mimetic evolution after
domesticated words. We get coined words.
The word meme is a good example,
deliberately coined sort of like GM food,
intelligently designed terms,
you can design them all day,
but whether they catch on depends
whether they replicate is that's the hard
part. So even though they are given
a boost by human intelligence,
they still have to survive by
differential replication in the society.
Most coined words don't.
Then we get to technical terms,
which are
very deliberately created,
designed and,
and their reproduction is fostered by
careful training and and examination and
sort of group pressure. You to get
everybody on the same page here.
Now phenotype genotype,
if you don't understand
that you fail a class.
So we,
those are sort of hyper
domesticated words where we're very,
we expand a lot of energy and time to
make sure they replicate and that they
record replicate accurately.
And then we get to internet means,
and a lot of people would say the
Internet means or sort of a reductio ad
absurdum of Dawkins' concept of memes.
And I used to think that myself about,
I think that's too bad.
This wonderful term is being
hijacked and used in this dumb way.
And then I realized,
and the reason I thought it was too bad
because an intelligently designed meme
is a contradiction in terms.
You might think it's supposed to
be an evolutionarily designed,
bottom up designed cultural item.
But my gosh,
they have contests to see who can
design the most viral Internet meme.
That's manifestly, these are, this
is an attempted intelligent design.
But is this a reductio ad? Absurdum
no. Is this a contradiction in terms?
Well, in a way, yes.
But so what a splittable ass who Adam
is also a contradiction in terms,
but nobody goes around saying
there's no such thing as an atom.
So what we have to recognize,
and one of the main points of my book
is to show that darkens concept of memes
does just fine as long as we allow for
the fact that the evolutionary process
that enables cultural evolution changes,
that evolution itself
evolves into a process,
which is evermore like what tradition
tells us cultural evolution is namely
intelligently designed
treasures that are understood,
bequeath to the young,
uh, et Cetera, et cetera.
So that traditional views of culture
are sort of limiting cases of cultural
evolution.
And in between we have every combination
and degree of 70 insightful tinkering.
One of my favorite examples is the
Polynesian canoe. I'm not going.
Uh, and this is where I got the
quote that I'm going to read,
but it turns out that the philosopher
who who was writing it was not writing
about Polynesian canoes,
but about French fishing boats.
Every boat is copied from another boat.
Let's reason was follows
in the manner of Darwin,
it's clear that a very badly made boat
will end up on the bottom after one or
two voyages and us never be copied.
One could say then with complete rigor
that it is to see herself who fashions
the boats, choosing those which
function and destroying the others.
That's natural selection.
If comes back, copy it.
If it floats, copy it and notice it. This,
that's the tradition that
you're working under.
You don't have to know
why it's a good boat.
You might be all wrong about why it's a
good boat if you're just conservative.
I don't know why they do it this way,
but grandpa did it this way.
I'm going to do it this way. And by and
large, if it ain't broke, don't fix it.
And gradually the design
will stabilize and uneven,
improve all without any
comprehension required. In fact,
comprehension can stand in the way.
You can have a brilliant idea,
which turns out to be just wrong.
Mother Nature punishes you for that.
So in this diagram,
the traditional model of culture as well,
and the upper upper reaches
up near the ceiling.
It's the economic model of culture
where we think of culture as treasures,
you know, high culture, opera, museums,
technology science,
the declaration of independence,
all that wonderful stuff
which we appreciate,
preserve honor,
make sure that our children
and grandchildren, uh,
take control of them and
appreciate the value of,
of keeping them alive and sober.
The preservation of our culture.
And that's a very real phenomenon.
But what we have to realize is
that that's the icing on the cake.
In addition to all the treasures of
culture. There's all the trash of culture,
all the junk,
all the graffiti,
all this stuff that's just fad and
fancy aid comes along for the ride.
Okay?
Because it can,
that's it.
It has its own fitness independently
of what we think of it.
Some of it we'd love to eradicate
and if only we could, but we can't.
So now we're living in the
age of intelligent design
and cultural evolution is to
become every more top down,
evermore comprehending
and self comprehending,
evermore refined in its search methods.
And of course the same thing has been
true genetic evolution because we now have
GM food and we have Craig vendor,
et Cetera, et Cetera, et cetera.
So we seem to be entering a new,
wonderful world with
Google leading the way.
But I want to suggest that what we're
doing is we're entering the age of post
intelligent design.
Okay?
Why?
Because in many fields,
intelligent designers are
exploiting the truth of Oracle.
Second rule that evolution
is cleverer than you are.
Genetic Algorithms, deep learning,
evolutionary architecture,
nanotechnology,
uh,
breeding nanotechnology by
making a novel proteins in a,
in a evolutionary setting,
machine learning.
Okay.
These are technologies which
wonderful epistomological
competences without comprehension.
Okay.
Watson Beats Ken Jennings in jeopardy.
Google translate,
lovely example of competence
without comprehension and many,
many others. And in
fact, in science itself,
we're now getting black box science
where you got a box designed by some
wonderful technocrats. You'd put
the data in, you push the button,
you get an answer,
which you can prove is highly reliable,
better than you could do using
the old fashioned methods.
Do you understand how it does
it? No. Do you have to know?
So we're moving away from
the ideal of comprehension
that
created intelligent
design in the first place.
One little bit. And then
I'll close on this. Uh,
Noam Chomsky is famous for distinguishing
between what do he cause problems
versus mysteries.
I'm 90 call some puzzles,
problems we can solve like evolution and
quantum mechanics and plate tectonics
and meteorology and the big bang.
And then there's mysteries which are
beyond human. Ken Now and forever.
I find that,
uh,
I really dislike that idea
because it's so defeatist.
Basically says, give up. Don't even try.
But he's inspired some people,
some philosophers in particular to become
what has become known as Mysterians
who make a point.
I,
I think they should wear bags over
their head for saying things like this.
Make a point of declaring.
We will never understand it.
Well,
speak for yourself.
The rest of us are going to go
on and try it if you don't mind.
So I used to have a very, very dim view
of this whole approach and I still do,
but Tom's, he's recently changed his tune.
I want to draw your attention to this.
In 2014 he said the following things, you
know, I think this was on the podcast,
while there's a conceptual distinction
between problems and Mr EDC says,
we accept the best explanation
as science can give us,
even when we can't imagine how they work.
It doesn't matter what
we can conceive anymore.
We've given up on that.
Well,
there's comprehension matter.
Do we want post comprehension science?
Okay,
do we want to technological
competence without comprehension.
Darpa has gotten into the act with a
new initiative for so explainable AI,
which seems to be directed
precisely this issue.
It's going to make ais that can
explain their results to us.
Poor adults who are using the systems.
Is that a good idea?
I think it depends on how it's done.
Should we try to make persons out
of these explaining ais? I think no.
On the pro pro side it seems,
well that's great.
They can explain their reasoning to
us so then they can develop their own
imaginative curiosity and epistemic goals.
We sure we want to do that.
I think we shouldn't because it's going
to blur the lines of moral responsibility
because they don't have skin in the
game and we want the people who make the
decisions that really matter to
take moral responsibility for them.
And we can do this with
some legal innovations.
We could license users of these new,
the epistemological black boxes and
they would have to prove that they
understood the limitations and the
boundaries of any system that they used.
And as it were made money using,
they would be morally responsible for
any misuse of anything that came out of
the box that they use.
And they would not be able to declare
whether who didn't understand,
because you'd have a strict liability
law was it doesn't matter whether you
understand you want to use this
tool you have to take as it were,
the risk of being held liable
for something if it goes wrong.
That's a bracing test,
but it's a good one.
It keeps people very honest, keeps,
gives them a real sense of due diligence
and keeps them from just taking the
manufacturer's word for it and
running off into the sunset.
Makers should have the responsibility and
we have the incentive to advertise all
the flaws,
gaps and weaknesses of their systems.
Advertising even you might even have,
I think it would be a good thing,
have sort of tutorial
programs built into them.
You can't use this system
until you can spot the flaws.
Now this is going to take you 10 or 20
hours depending on how clever you are to
really get to understand what's real
and what's facade in this system.
I think that would be a very good idea.
Many years ago we at Tufts,
my colleague Jordan Smith and
I created the software studio,
the curricular software studio,
and the idea was to use computers to,
to enhance human imagination.
We called them imagination prostheses
and what one of our metaphors was,
there's two kinds of empowerment.
There's the bulldozer and
the Nautilus machine way,
the bulldozer where you
can move a mountain,
but you're still a 98 pound weakling.
The Nautilus machine is a technology that
which actually enhances your strength,
your personal strength. And we want
to do the same thing for imagination.
We want to make imagination enhancers,
systems that help people become better
thinkers independently of the system
they're using.
I think we want to make AI's that
are nautilus machines for the mind,
not bulldozers, tools, not colleagues.
Thank you for your attention.
[inaudible] there's microphones.
Anybody that has up questions
should step up to the microphone.
All right, your friends
for coming. Thank you.
I'm very interested to read your book and
I was just going through the index and
I see you mentioned,
um,
Kaufman and Deacon Terrence Deacon
Deacon a few times and I was wondering,
trying to get the scaffolding right in
my mind when you refer to Deakin and, uh,
the book,
can you kind of put that in perspective
against what you're saying that there's
purposelessness in the lower forms of
life because it Kinda more my reading of
him would be the,
I can incomplete nature like heirs to
Tilian final cause starts to emerge
spontaneously.
It rather lower levels of order.
Well, in fact, I think
Terry and I agree, uh,
although we'll put it in slightly
different ways. Um, Louisa,
I did a long and really favorable
review of, of, of deacons book.
It's on my website. Um, and uh,
deacon changed my mind about something
that I think is really important and
that's what I discuss in this book.
Okay.
He argues that
brilliant though
touring and Newell Newell,
Simon Mccarthy,
Minsky and, uh, Shannon, let's say,
are the brilliant as the
simplifications that they
created,
which made the computer age possible.
There's an important regard in which
they've let us into the wrong set of
architectures
because all the architectures
that are made possible
by their simplifications
involve a separation of
energy and information.
You don't have to worry. A computer
doesn't have to worry about words,
where it's going to get, it's, it's,
it's voltage from it's computers,
parasitic
on us. And he says, life isn't like that.
The thing that is most
important about say,
a brain who is that those individual
neurons are semi autonomous.
And you have to remember they are,
the way I put it in the book,
there are the direct descendants of free
floating you carry out that fended for
themselves in a difficult
ocean environment for
millions of years before they
ever became parts of
multicellular organisms.
What are they doing in there?
They're trying to stay alive.
This is deacons point.
You make me an architecture of basic
parts which are trying to stay alive.
What you're looking for work that's
going to be a really different computer
architecture room. Anything that we
see coming out of the sort of fun,
Wyman tradition,
even programs which
have some of the flavor.
Um,
well
production systems and,
and uh,
many architectures of good old fashioned
AI had this nice sort of competitive
feelings, but they, they're not, it's
not fundamental enough. So I think,
I think Deakin's book hard as it is a
very good read for the reasons that I
described in the book. Uh, but
I don't think that he says,
and if he does, this will be a
point of disagreement with him that
teleology in any sort of very
strong sense comes in. Well,
I agree that it comes in with the,
with the, with the origin of life.
I've got a whole section of
what happened before bacteria.
That's to me one of my
favorite sections in the book,
talking about how life
could ever get started.
And what I argued there is the
teleology comes in gradually as we move,
as I put it from how come to what?
For two different why questions
I to teach my students this.
I have a pair of examples.
MMM.
Why are planets spiritual?
Why are ball bearings spherical?
There's a reason. There's a what
for, for the ball bearings, whatnot.
For the planets.
Why aren't asteroids spherical?
Why aren't dice satirical?
It was a how come for the asteroids
and what for, for the dice.
What Darwin's brilliant permitted was
to how we move from a universe of planet
where there's only,
how come there's no teleology to
a world in which there's what,
four where things have purposes and
functions and that is itself a gradual
process.
Okay.
And I think he agrees with that.
Oh,
um,
hi. Uh, I'm a, I'm a fan of yours.
I'm also a fan of David Chalmers and I,
I sort of have a question for you. Maybe
you've kind of answered this already. Um,
which like I, I'm curious
as to like when, uh,
when something sort of becomes
like a moral agent, we're like,
when you're not an agent but
rather like a patient, like when,
when does something,
when does it have interests that matter?
Well,
that do
well, right. So,
but I wonder though that like if I'm a
moral patient and I have like a nerve
which causes pain and I'm
trying to avoid that, uh,
how's that different from like
a computer that I'm programming,
which has like a cable on which,
you know, a signal is transmitted,
which might be the pain signal of some
sort of mind that we don't comprehend
yet.
Well, you know, um, we
addressed that very issue.
Um, in Rod Brooks lab when
we were building cog, what,
15 years ago, the humanoid robot, um,
and Carl had these motors that stuck
out of its elbows and they were a little
bit fragile and we didn't want cognitive
be able to move at times so that it
would, uh, uh, damaged them.
So we sort of gave it a,
I gave her the funny bone
so that if it ever did anything bumped,
it's these murders,
it sent an effect of pain signal.
It was an awesome, do that again.
So yeah,
we can have a functional,
this was of course a top down designed
the system to give Kog the humanoid
robot, a quiz.
I equate I pain system because it had
some of the functions of a paint system.
And if we'd continued with that and
expanded it by many orders of magnitude,
the project
made some wonderful progress,
but you know,
not 1% of what you'd have to do.
Um,
then eventually we would have had a robot
that would have interests and where it
would be wrong to thwart,
thwart those interests. It would be
capable of something like suffering.
But we never got that far.
Okay.
Thanks.
But I don't think there's,
you mentioned traumas.
I don't think there's a sort of extra
Zoe ingredient quality or something which
the living things have and the
things made of silicon don't have,
I think that's, uh, just
a bad idea. Well, I,
I think Tom,
I'm not saying Chalmers is right,
but I think he would go
towards the direction of,
even silicon has that like your pen
psychos him or something like that.
But next, next, yeah.
Panpsychism is the view that everything
is everything. Everything is conscious.
And I think,
I almost agree with it, but I, I just
got to change the view a little bit.
I call my view Pan Nifty Islam,
everything is nifty. Have we, Adam
is nifty. Every electrons nifty.
Now the question is, is
there any difference between
Panpsychism Pan, nifty Islam?
They both explained the same things,
namely nothing.
Okay.
If you can tell me how panpsychism is
an improvement over Penn nifty ism,
I'd be very interested to learn.
Well,
it's because conscious things
are made out of conscious things.
Oh really?
That's it.
Colored things aren't made
out of colored things.
No.
Yeah. Thanks for coming. Uh, honored that.
Sure. A year. I'm also a big fan. Uh,
you mentioned skin in the game and uh,
the idea of building into, into, I dunno,
into economics or into legal systems,
uh,
the incentives for makers
and users of tools to,
to have, to deal with the implications
of the tools of using those tools.
But I was wondering, and I guess that's
more a question of politics or economics,
how realistic that is. I am thinking
particularly of, uh, of, uh,
I don't know, fake news,
alternative facts. The use
of media and social media to,
to spread viral means intentionally to,
to provoke a human action.
To one direction or the
other. And uh, that is, I,
I feel that that is its own incentive.
The possibility of doing that is so
powerful that it's very hard at this stage
to build limitations to do
that for simple things like,
like Internet means misuse,
Internet meme, slat alone, uh, uh,
AI tools or whatever like that. So, well,
I hear you.
I think this is,
I think we underestimate how
serious these problems are.
I don't share your pessimism,
but I agree it's almost too late and we
ought to be thinking a lot harder and a
lot faster and we ought to be acting more
to try to fend off the trends that we
can see happening. I think that
really it is the response and boy,
if there's any audience in the world,
I want to spread this
message to a Psu folks
think very hard about what the
unintended consequences of some of the
innovations are and whether there are
ways of steering them down more socially
benign directions.
I think there are,
and I think the time is short,
but I think we should
get cracking on it now.
Okay. So there's, uh, just to
follow up shortly on that, uh,
it's there,
there's a,
there's such a thing as a
personal interest in such a
thing as group interest in
such a thing as like [inaudible]
interests, however defined society.
So is there's a bit of, uh, uh,
is there a bit of a conflict there
and how so you say we should do this,
but of course for all of these situations
there's this personal interest by a
certain group. So I, I, I,
you're doing your part by spreading
the right meme site, I think. And, uh,
well thank you. Um, uh, I'm
certainly trying. Um, I think that
actually one of the,
one of the most heartening
changes that I see on the, uh,
in the recent development is that now
that silicon valley is reducing all these,
um,
young plutocrats young billionaires
and a lot of them are really taking
seriously the idea of putting,
putting that vast economic power
they have to socially benign,
uh, projects and they're taking
seriously good intentions aren't enough.
They've got to figure out what you can
really mess things up by squandering a
fortune with good
intentions on a bad idea.
And I think that this ideal
of having,
taking it as a personal responsibility
to use this incredible economic power for
good and the fact you,
you help each other do it better.
This is one of the best
developments I've seen and
we're not quite at the point where we
can start seriously shaming those who
don't treat their wealth that way.
And I don't think we're going to have to,
it shaming doesn't usually work anyway,
but if we can
make them feel like they're
sort of second class,
then this would be a stepped forward.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Hi. I want to ask you about, uh,
I guess language and kind of the,
the limits there of it and try to get
a little bit at a tension that I think
came up in your talk. So this
is a little bit about, uh,
the Chomsky criticism that you give
and a little bit about sort of the,
the tension between Anglo American
analytic philosophy and the European
continental tradition. So it
sounds like on the one hand, um,
your, your um, your challenging
Chomsky and saying that, uh,
that you know,
reason in language kind of has a mapping
to the real world that we can explain
and that there's, there isn't, there
isn't really a limit to language, right?
These mysteries don't exist.
They're not beyond human thought.
They're not beyond perception
or methods of expressing them.
But then at the end of your talk when you
started talking about, uh, the dangers,
at least what I perceive as you've
mentioned and the dangers of AI about
competence without comprehension,
it sounds to me like the,
the fear there actually is very much
that it's encroaching on the head Germany
of language, right? That we,
what we don't want to happen is to have
meaning or something extra, you know,
act like outside of the scope of meaning.
Um,
that that kind of messes up
our whole calculus, right?
Morality stops making sense. Epistemology
stops making sense. Ontology like the,
that these concepts and things that we
say are so had demonic and really do have
this very concrete mapping to
physical things starts to go away.
And so I'm curious,
you know,
kind of sounds like you're saying both
things that on the one hand there's a
danger to like meaning escaping us.
And then on the other hand,
we actually have had Germany over this.
That's good.
I hadn't thought of tying it to the
different between no continental and the
Anglo phone analytic philosophy,
uh,
aside from thinking that
with a few exceptions,
the anglophone philosophers are
not postmodernists and don't,
and it's still have a proper
respect for truth facts.
And I think that the damage done by
postmodernist to the very ideal of
objectivity and truth is that's vandalism.
And one thing I said,
which I maybe didn't stress enough
at this time,
let's look at science.
Do you have competition out
who can make the cheapest,
fastest gene sequencer?
And it's getting really cheap and fast
and you just push the buttons and it's
like, it's like a TV. You just, you know,
put it in the microwave and push
the button and out it comes. Uh,
it's amazing how much of that process,
which,
which took genius.
Okay.
Which took brilliant drudgery by,
by Nobel laureate scientist to
do within my adult lifetime.
And now you just push a
button and you get it. Uh,
but look at,
so there's competition among different
makers of gene sequencing machinery and w
w what's the benchmark?
Why do you buy unit a rather than unity?
Cause you know,
well maybe cause it's cheaper,
but not if it's not as accurate.
Okay.
Truth really matters.
It's,
it is a,
it is a design in the same way that,
hmm.
Uh,
fuel efficiency or safety or
design requirements for cars.
So getting it right is
taken for granted as a,
as a requirement for the
scientific black boxes or,
you know,
getting it right with a high,
a high degree of reliability
of the probability now.
Mm.
I can't yet.
I don't know of any black boxes
that are
trying to avoid that and are
just trying to make memes.
It'll spread truth be damned,
a utility be down. But maybe there are,
in which case that's a very ominous
development.
Well,
on that apolitical,
no
thank you.
[inaudible].